these are the last men to have been
killed defending nagorno caraba in a
conflict that has cost tens of thousands
of Armenian and aabani lives while aaban
became much more powerful militarily
over the past two decades it was the
changing priorities of armenia's
traditional supporter that allowed Baku
to make its final move to capture
carabat Russia wash
washed its hands after beginning a war
in
Ukraine uh South f as
kabak Etc all this is not center of
Russian thinking uh they guys are busy
guys are busy in Ukraine they are busy
both technically for example we don't
have weapon from them which we had
before
politically uh you know Putin every
morning does not look at the map of
nagoro kabak he looks at other maps and
although our Mania has recently tried to
strengthen its relationships with the US
and European countries none of them
rushed to stand in azan's way either
Armenia is a small country surrounded by
much more powerful neighbors turkey Iran
and now oil and gas Rich aaban the
government here says one of its
priorities is now its relationships with
those countries and Armenia has angered
Russia by its decision to join the
international criminal court which has
issued an arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin making Europe Van's Regional
diplomacy even more
important does Armenia
feel uh a bit lonely in this part of the
world at the
moment you know um we never felt
ourselves lonely because we had a lot of
you know countries which are supported
us before but simultaneously we
understand perfectly well that for
solving our problems we are alone the
geopolitics actually changed the region
geopolitics changed the Europe
geopolitics changing the the situation
in the world so uh In This Very alarming
world you should find the proper ways of
Defending Your sovereignity your
territorial integrity and building the
new kind of relationship with your
neighbors thousands of lives could have
been saved if various attempts to find
Common Ground between Armenia and aaban
over the last 30 years had been
successful now the ethnic Armenians
dream of self-government or their own
state in nagoro caraba is over Bernard
Smith Al jaera
Yer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer